all right our next
speaker spent 15 years living in New
Zealand the birthplace of
our so everyone please welcome when
excited to be here and I'm super excited
to talk about the art project Sprint
does anyone know what the art project
Sprint
is no okay good then you are so I'm so
glad you came to my top I can tell you
what the Sprint is so um let me just
start by asking does anyone have any
idea how old R
is oh in the back 20 years right yeah
when was it it was it was it was um it
was U launched I guess in the year 2020
so it is about 20 years old um but the
coding any guesses on how old the coding
might be yes
I
well you're very close you're very close
but the people who started coding in R
so I happen to know Ross eaka who was
one of the people who invented R they
started coding R in
1987 so this is a really old language
right it's been around for a really
really long time in fact this is the
email that Ross eha sent from Auckland
from New Zealand where he's saying you
know this is the our court team right so
so it's been around a really long time
and of course that means what that the
hardore team is guess
what it's getting old exactly that's the
whole point the hard court team is
getting old and why should we care if
the our core team is getting old because
everything that we've done that we've
talked about today is based on what
these 20 people in the world who are in
charge of our core and all of our
programming language and they're getting
old so this is what the the problem that
the r project Sprint addresses and the r
contributors working group is also
addressing is how do we transfer all of
this huge amount of knowledge that
they've been acquiring for 40 years into
people who might we expect to live
longer right so this is the issue that
we're addressing okay so what does Bas R
look like well this is something that
Paul mural did Paul mural is uh um one
of the our court team members and he did
this in JavaScript and let me see if I
can get this to point any giftes let's
see oops no that's not what I wanted to
do but anyway let's see let me try
another okay so here we have all of
these things this is the the this is
actually the link to the slide but this
is the library and the source code and
all this documentation and tests and
packages and that stuff there um so this
is all of Base R but before we go into
talking a little bit about the r project
sprank I just wanted to introduce you to
the r core team so here's the rore team
the first people these were the people
that invented it the University of
Auckland in the 90s actually going back
to
1987 um Robert gentleman and Ross eaka
um Martin mockler we can really thank
because he's the one that convinced them
to make it open source right if we
didn't have Martin we wouldn't it
wouldn't have been open source it would
have been something you'd have to
purchased um Simon urbanex he's um
someone back there was talking about s
he's the only person to have worked in
Bell Labs where s was invented and at
the University of Auckland where R was
invented and he's in charge of the Apple
guey so anytime Apple changes their
software he updates our to teach it how
to interact with that
software um Thomas Lumley my PhD
supervisor he does surveys and he also
is in in charge of Statistics this is
Martin plumber he also does statistics
um you know they just work on this the
some of the stats project packages and
make sure that they're correct Deen
sarker he is um he was in charge of code
code completion so so anytime you type
something into R there's kind of this
code completion and that is how he got
access to the r source code and became
an our qu team member um and then Thomas
Calabar he's kind of the newest Our
cortin member of course there's more but
um but he is the one that has this huge
server and he spins up a new version of
R before before they release it to make
sure and does all the tests to make sure
that it's not going to It's Not Gon to
break anything important right um right
and then of course we have more and more
people one of the other PE people I just
alluded to earlier was um Paul mural and
she only touches these green things here
he touches grid he touches graphics and
he touches the graphic devices right so
this to me was a huge you know something
I was super excited about hearing the
reason for that is because I often feel
terrible that I can't do the whole thing
but the truth is is that not even people
who are members of the AR core team can
do the whole thing right they just have
their little pockets that they deal with
and so that's really wonderful it's just
like such a relief for me okay so what
we're gonna talk about next is like who
has things that really bother them about
art does anyone have anything that
really bothers them about
R what's your
thing dictionaries the better you don't
like the dictionaries okay what
else oh my
goodness what else what else okay so
here's one thing that bothers the hell
out of me uh vectorize you know at the
very beginning of your code you have to
have library library library library
library libr Library you can't just have
library and then all the names of all
the packages that you want to introduce
it just drives me crazy right so this is
one bug this could be a bug you could
call it a bug in R we want to be able to
vectorize these you know Library we want
to put a vector in we want to put in
like load all these packages and then
just load it in one thing and supposed
to having library liary library library
labber labber laber labber laber it's
just a big pain okay so this is one one
problem that we have but what do you do
if you want to tell people about you
know a problem that you have in in art
this is what you do you have this
there's this big bugzilla list I I copy
this on Monday can you believe that
there's there are this many things wrong
with our like isn't that unbelievable to
me that's unbelievable but of course we
are part of a completely untraditional
community and so there's a much
different way to do that which is just
to put it on social media and and say
please I am so sick of this thing about
R can you update it and so that's what
this person did here he's in uh where
was he he's in Australia and he went to
the r source code and he said I really
want three-digit hex hex codes in the
our source code this is where it needs
to be updated does this bother anyone
else now do does it bother anyone else
or not you you never thought about it
well this is someone who thought about
it and he was like I really want it
updated and this is where it needs to be
updated okay so in August we got
together and uh guess what we
did we updated the darn Cod right
because what he did and our source code
is available on the web I can tell you
where where to look for Winston Chang
has it on his there's a mirror there too
but he says look this page line 365 of
the our swords code all you need to do
is update this and then what we did here
line 365 five we put it in right so
there you go but not only do you need to
update the source code what else do you
need to update any
guesses documentation good work next we
update the documentation right here
right because you saw there was the
documentation all at the top but then
what do you need to do next after you do
the
documentation testing exactly so then we
write the test so that's our testing
here right
right because this is a story I heard
Paul mural he he put in something with
um with our um what was I gonna say he
updated grid once and you know what he
did he broke because grid is the basis
for GG plot he broke GG plot and he
broke a thousand packages at the same
time so you have to be damn careful with
your code if you're going to be doing
this kind of stuff right you don't want
to do that okay
so here we go we've updated it and guess
what we have one happy user in the room
I am so happy it took you three days and
you updated my bug in art and this is so
wonderful right how cool is that I have
never seen advaned in software based on
a social media post but this is so this
is like my very first case study and I'm
just so happy about it okay so other
buds that we dealt with and of course
here we have here before we do that let
me just talk about my friend amadu so
this is amadu uh from um senagal he was
he was one of the members of of the art
project Sprint this is Sarah G Carr and
this is you can see Shannon P py
something anyway this is why Jared
doesn't introduce last names he just
says but anyway so this is amadu and
he's submitting his first patch right so
if you fix R you submit a patch and he
just he just submitted his first patch
isn't that wonderful right
so um other things that we wanted to
update this is another one uh Alpha math
so what does the alpha do what's the
alpha value for in GD plot who
remembers op right and so here we have
we have opacity Apple updated their
software so the courtz is now now you
can include opacity and we wrote coding
for this here we go you are seeing the
very first
for our print our our thing that has
some opacity in the courts right here
live on screen how exciting is that
thank you thank you so it's right there
and um and uh then here's some other the
other work that a whole bunch of people
did which is this translations dashboard
so let me show you the translations
dashboard which is really really
amazing here they are translating R into
like
24 different languages so that it's not
only people that speak English so you
don't have this extra barrier of
learning right um here's the web let me
show you and um I think I'm gonna come
on web late oh right and so here this is
how much we have updated right so
obviously we're not doing very well in
Albanian but our French and our German
is doing well any of you who speak any
other languages if you want to
participate in this you you absolutely
can so here we have Turkish here we have
polish here we have
Norwegian and then um you know this is
how much is translated ver versus how
many people actually speak the language
in the world um this is how many
translators we have and so they spent a
lot of time working on translating this
and in fact one of the other things that
they're working on um is going to be
translating
um translating more the documentation
right because some of the documentation
isn't there well um the other thing I
wanted to tell you about is here we all
are oops let me go back to the slide
this is not what I wanted to show
here and let me go back to the
slide okay and then here we go here and
here's the picture of all of us I hate
having my picture taken so I'm hdden
back there with my mask on um here is
Heather Turner who organized it all this
is Luke Cherney he's also an artcore
team member I'm sure you could like pick
out the artcore team members right
obiously like a bodal distribution in
age and then here's Thomas Lumley um and
all of us this let me see if I can bu
amaju who was the person that was
submitting the bug which I I he's over
here in the corner there so there we are
and if you want to participate in
updating R and keeping it up today and
if you want to learn C which is one of
the r learning C we spent a lot of time
learning C together as a group before we
got together um you can join this our
contributors uh working group which is
on Meetup Meetup and you can email
Heather Turner you can get a bugzilla
account you can post on social media
about your complaints and your issues
and uh and if you're lucky then uh
someone might hear you so anyway thank
you very much for coming to my TED
talk let's let's make sure we can keep
our alive kind of indefinitely we don't
want it to die with a with a with some
of these people that know everything so
anyway talk to you
later